I think one of the most iconic things
about the queen was a handbag she always
carried a Lorna handbag and they carry
the Royal warrant I think it will
forever be the bag that is synonymous
with the queen she kept very little in
it a package of mints a crisply folded
five pound note a compact mirror and her
lipstick but she was never without that
bag and that bag served another really
useful purpose other than finishing off
her outfit beautifully she would use
that bag to communicate messages if the
bag moved from one hand to another it
meant the queen wanted to be moved on
whoever she was speaking to was deeply
dull if she put the bag on the floor it
meant she wanted to get out of that
situation immediately so the bag was
really fundamental in her conveying
messages to her staff I think the queen
style has had an influence actually on
the younger Roars I think when you look
to the Duchess of Cambridge who has very
much her own sense of style we know
she's aligned herself with the likes of
Alexander McQueen and some top-end
designers but actually the Queen's habit
of recycling her wardrobe is something
that Kate has really been Keen to
emulate because of course the Royals
don't want to be seen to be overspending
certainly not when it comes to their
wardrobe and so the queen was very good
at re-wearing clothes Princess Anne when
I sat down to interview her and
complimented her on her dress told me it
was 30 years old and Kate does the same
she recycles her wardrobe they want to
look Frugal and they want to look
sustainable
oh
foreign